من دون مفاجاه احتل الصداره مره اخرى انه
حزب اليمين المحافظ اليوناني المسمى
الديمقراطيه الجديده لكن فوزه هذا لا
يمكنه من تشكيل حكومه جديده بمفرده لذلك
فضل رئيس الحكومه ميتس الذهاب مباشره الى
جوله ثانيه الشهر المقبل ليظل ممسكا وحده
بدواليب السلطه ويتفادى اي تحالفات قد
تربك مسيره اصلاحاته
اننا بحاجه الى حكومه تؤمن حقا بالاصلاحات
وقادره على تنفيذها وهذا لا يمكن ان يتم
باغلبيه هشه او تحالفات ضعيفه من جهه
سانفذ ما التزمت به وساتخذ جميع الاجراءات
وفقا للدستور
جوله ثانيه للانتخابات التشريعيه ستكرس
بقاء اليمين المحافظ في السلطه وتعزز
حدوده بالحصول على اغلبيه مريحه
واذا كان الحزب الحاكم قد خلص العجز العام
ورفع معدل النمو فان الناخب اليوناني يريد
انعكاسا ايجابيا حقيقيا على حياته اليوميه
وليس فقط نيله رضا الاتحاد الاوروبي
وصندوق النقد الدولي
خارجيا واقليميا اليمين المحافظ يريد ان
يكون الحارس الاول لحدود اوروبا الجنوبيه
الشرقيه لا سيما في وجه اللاجئين الجدد
وان يحسن من سمعه بلاده التي شوهتها ازمه
الديون اما الخاسر الاكبر في هذه العمليه
الانتخابيه فهو تحالف اليسار الراديكالي
المسمى سرز بقياده رئيس الحكومه السابق
الاكسس وبعد احلام الحمله الانتخابيه ها
هو يقر بالهزيمه ويسر على خوض الجوله
الثانيه ومن اسباب هزيمته انه جرب الحكم
ولم يكن اداؤه مرضيا للشعب
الانتخابات لم تنتهي بعد ومن المحتمل جدا
اجراء انتخابات ثانيه لذلك ليس لديهم
التسع من الوقت وعلى الفور لابد من اجراء
كل تغييرات اللازمه لخوض المعركه
الانتخابيه المقبله بافضل الطرق الممكنه
ومهما كانت الظروف الداخليه اليونانيه فان
كرسي السلطه ازداد بعدا عن اليسار اما
الظروف التي تعيشها اوروبا سياسيا وامنيا
واقتصاديا فكلها تجنح بالافكار والاصوات
فقط الى اليمين اليمين المحافظ اليوناني
منتشيا باحتلاله الصداره يريد ان يحكم
البلاد وحده من دون حاجه لتحالفات اليسار
المعارض الذي كرست هذه الانتخابات تراجعه
يقول انه يستعد للجوله الثانيه والمؤشرات
ترجح انها ستكون معركه خاسره هي الاخرى
اما الناخبون فيتطلعون الى ترجمه الوعود
وتحسين المعيشه عيش دراجي الجزيره اثينا